[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday July 5th
Hank I don't know if you know this but
yesterday was America's big birthday
everybody was really excited about it it
was all over the news
and of course the way that we celebrate
America's birthday is by pretending to
have a war if you don't think that we
celebrate America's birthday by
pretending to have a war listen to this
that's me recording from a roof deck in
downtown Indianapolis Indiana
Hank Indiana is one of those states
where all fireworks are legal like not
just bottle rockets and the little
things that spin and whippersnappers but
also bombs Hank I've always believed
that there's a very short list of people
who should be able to own explosives
people who work in demolition the army
and of course wily coyote if you're not
directly employed in the demolition
business or in the armed forces or wily
coyote I cannot imagine a reason why you
need to have a bomb but the state of
Indiana doesn't agree with me they give
rockets and bombs to pretty much anyone
over the age of 18 who is able to
convince a person at a fireworks stand
that they aren't a terrorist Hank I will
admit that when I was younger fireworks
used to make me feel patriotic but now
they just make me feel scared I mean
look at me Hank that was pretty much my
posture for the entire evening for God's
sakes there were bombs going off all
around us and they were all being set
off by drunk people look at those guys
those guys are demolition experts make
at my head okay okay okay okay I'm
having some anxiety
okay goldfish nerdfighters and then once
the regular people were done firing off
all of their fireworks it was time for
the government to fire off its fireworks
and Hank here's where the evening got
pretty freaking nuts
in Indianapolis there's a radio station
q95 and if you tuned to that radio
station during the fireworks display
they kind of play a soundtrack for the
fireworks it's like an officially
sanctioned thing the fireworks
themselves are known as the Regents bank
freedom blast sorry
it's called the freedom blast Hank I
mean you can't make this crap up and so
the freedom blast has a soundtrack
unfortunately the person that Sarah and
I were we
knew about this so we were able to
listen to the soundtrack I hope you're
ready to believe in America again Hank
because what you're about to see and
hear is going to change you
wait are they mashing up Neil Diamond
and Martin Luther King
you aren't seriously mashing up Neil
Diamond and Martin Luther King you're
embarrassing us so Hank here's the long
and short of it last night
we celebrated our independence by having
a pretend war that was sponsored by a
bank welcome to America I'll see you
tomorrow